hey it's me another video
another day another video you know how
all these skin youtubers just go
oh guys i've been making videos for
three years every single day
boo hoo every single day
i don't take breaks is it even eight
years
how long have i been doing this
motherflipping nine years
let's begin lawyer everyone's favorite
show
leave your entries in the subreddit
and i'll watch submissions in the next
episode
i am honored to be army general of the
nine-year-old army and i'm ready to host
meme review i am blue shirt kid
well anyway i think it's safe to say
that anyone that gets a hundred thousand
upvotes
will automatically get to host meme
review
blue shirt kid put on your finest blue
shirt cause it is time
to host meme review meme review with
such hosts as
elon musk and blue shirt
i mean i'm doubt i'll be in touch with
blue shirt kid check out your dms
never forgotten blue shirt kid i am also
on the side of pewdiepie
because i don't like t series personally
so if i'm in a bad mood
i can just watch him to feel better
so wholesome and sweet that was such a
great video i really enjoyed that
not the hero we deserve but the hero we
need
captain marcia everyone damn
an actual superhero with not the flat
ass am i right
sexually obviously now i wouldn't
normally pick on people's appearance but
i don't like brie larson ask me anything
i'll be answering it on my youtube
channel alright blue shirt kid
relax you're getting me in review and
that's final all right
where did you buy the blue shirt that's
what i want to know i like how this guy
just got like
instant internet fame could you lend me
the blue shirt
lawful good neutral good chaotic good
luck
this is actually very accurate they did
a good job getting all kinds of people
oh my god is my whole reddit taken over
by blue shirt kid
anime netflix adaptation incredible what
about the manga
did you know that the bones in your
fingers are shaped
like penises of course why else do you
think i eat g fuel with my fingers
cause i'm gay i'm gay son i like d
if you can't figure out the name of a
song just upload a video of you singing
it to youtube
and they'll copyright it oh my god
modern problems require modern solutions
i'm pretty sure this would work someone
should try this my final attempt at
posting here spent two months making it
i just want pewds to see it
now this guy went all out
it's another pewdiepie anime
oh god damn
nice holy sh
damn was that a devil man crybaby
reference
god damn that's awesome
if we do like an animation you should i
should voice act in swedish
just just a thought pigs your sampling
rate is set to 420
i fail to see any problem with that
that's the problem with the video
quality of your
camera should be able to change it to
anywhere in the settings well god damn
poop oh turns out it's stuck on 420.
listen i really try my best to fix the
quality
but uh this is pretty much imax
cinema quality so i think you guys
should be satisfied
with the quality of this video no stop
to celebrate international woman's day
tag the women creators who inspired you
gloria
borger that is so nice i really
appreciate that thank you rolic that's
gonna make her day
that's for sure this is my second fan
art this week why are you crying it's
awesome
thank you very much what is this an app
12 plus 12 paws to download the app i do
know that someone made a website i think
it's like pew news
yeah look pewters.org it looks legit
about hosts look at all these hosts
michelle obama so they have all the
topics we discussed that's funny
do you either write it down as well holy
someone's spending work
well done he needs to host meme review
nobody
pewdiepie subreddit basically the new
king do i even need to be here
every month you guys pick someone else
that you prefer i get it
okay everyone money is hard to get and
should only be spent on necessary stuff
mr beast what the f is that even
supposed to mean
i i still don't understand where mr
beast get all his money from
drug cartel please tell us mr peace i
want to know
pewdiepie and you laugh you lose
[Laughter]
hey look it's t-shirt kid again when
your kid asks
you why there are twerking videos
recommended to you
okay first of all because of the youtube
algorithm
that's a good meme that's a good meme
right there felix laugh
at our memes but never up but sometimes
i do okay
i'm just not logged in all right cry
more
shut up spider-man you're fat i made a
huge toy
with oh my god oh my
god what i fixed her what
chair launching whoa
that's incredible guys check out lost in
the fall a link in the description
only 135 subscribers i paused the
pewdiepie vid while my youtube was
lagging
big mistake oh my god he's taking over
me
the wishes child hey bros on may 31st we
should celebrate bride's birthday for
his
hard work editing pewds videos now hold
on just a second here
this is a try i've known brad for i
don't know how many years now
and every year i try and figure out when
his birthday is because he will never
say it
i know more or less the time frame
because his mom just
appears out of nowhere and bride just
goes yeah my mom is here sorry
i'm just like why is your mom here hmm
oh
it's birthday time but bride will not
tell anyone
when it's his birthday how did you
figure this out is this posted by secret
brad is this a trap
how did this random reddit person know
birthday
nice try brad now return to the dungeon
from whence pewds keep you that's right
bread nice try
appears five minutes before previous
gloria booga
uh no oh my god me telling my friend
why my meme with 1.8 000 up votes
didn't get into the y okay first of all
because of brad
petition for blue shirt kid to become
ceo of youtube jesus christ oh my god
when your friends ask you why you only
have four subscribers okay first of all
because of the youtube algorithm kids
are dumb changed my mind i changed my
mind
oh my god met pewter in iceland used his
camera to
take the [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] you could
how dare you is not my camera
then two your face seems to have better
quality
yeah what the hell he lives in 2040p
goddammit this is bullying
when your parents ask you why there's
hentai on your recommended
okay first of all because of the youtube
algorithm
i just noticed it's been lasagna
all along that's right everyone oh my
god
i didn't see the gpu i was like oh yeah
it's another one of these
oh g fuel 10 out of 10. very nice
wow you push the ass just drink g fuel
pathetic for legal disclaimer please do
drink the g
fuel and don't inhale it or any other
ways to eat it
thank you now i will continue my habits
periods i'm 1.8 meters also puts
bullying you were the chosen one you
were supposed to destroy teen series not
copy strikers
dr phil to the range okay let's get this
done
sony tv now it has been three days
and all my dr phil videos are still
claimed
except the ones i privated thank god now
i expect sony tv
to remove these claims immediately or
else i'm gonna drop a diss track on you
sony
you've seen what happened to t-series
their company is never going to recover
you don't want to make this enemy sony
atv remove the claims
immediately damn two new milestones we
hit 89 million subscribers and
lasagna is my most viewed video in
incredible i remember i had to skip an
upload to work on [ __ ] lasagna i'm like
oh god i missed one upload
this is terrible i think it paid off
i'm so proud i can't believe this
channel is still peaking
after nine years it's crazy thank you
guys so much for all the support it
genuinely means so much to me
smash like and i see you guys in the ba
bye tuber simulator it's now so relevant
that it's got a brand new mini game
craniac
drop the crane and get fresh items only
available
in the washing machine like game and you
say there's more of course there is
new knowledge perks new quests and new
pixellings
and legs guys
[Music]
like